Результати не видно відразу,
і спочатку витрати дуже високі, їм
потрібна громадська підтримка, тому це
поганий знак і поганий сигнал для
населення, а також для партнерів
за кордоном, ця особлива відставка з
німецької точки зору не буде  так само помітно,
як, наприклад,
відставка Сокка Шиле, однак це головна
реформа реформи, яку також
назвали в Німеччині прикладом
успіху в реформах. Ця серія
відставок зменшить довіру до
процесу реформ, а також підтримає
сили, які не обов’язково хочуть
припинити підтримувати Україну, і вони дадуть
їм аргументи для того, щоб не інвестувати стільки
в реформи в Україні, потребує
певності політичної волі на вищому рівні для
реформ, і всі ті, хто пішов у відставку,
вони, безумовно, ставлять під сумнів цю політичну
волю на  Інститут європейської
політики, безумовно, вірить в Україну, оскільки зараз
багато проектів, також я
вірю, що наш уряд вірить
в Україну  і Німеччина підтримує
цей процес реформ у кількості та
зусиллях надзвичайно масово, і я
вірю, що ми продовжуватимемо це робити